What does it mean to be
a featherless, two-legged,
linguistically conscious
creature born between urine
and feces--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--whose body will soon
be the culinary delight
of terrestrial worms?
That's what philosophy
is all about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Every generation of
the human species
has to come to terms with
how to love? How to live?
How are you going to
deal with a catastrophe?
preserve your style?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This class revolves around
three fundamental questions.
One, what does it
mean to be human?
Terrifying query.
Two, what are the forms
of love that constitute
the best of our humanity--
love of truth, love of
goodness, love of beauty.
Third, how does community,
tradition, heritage
shape and mold our conceptions
of who we are as human beings?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you listen to music, you
have to be willing to smile
when you didn't
expect it, or cry
when you had no sense of
where your tears come from.
That's in part what
it means to wrestle
with that terrifying
question of, what
does it mean to be human?
And then be willing to get out
of your unique and singular
skin and imagine what it's
like to be in the
skin of others,
others in every
corner of the globe.
I am Cornel West, and
this is MasterClass.